boyo and the structure is compromised it
falls in on itself that's too much
that's why the World Trade Center didn't
fall over who could have been had to be
detonated because that's the way it
falls did it they put do they put
charges and there is that what the I
don't know you can see or did they do
that in or did maybe Alex Jones has a
theory on on the Mexico earthquake
[ __ ] frogs day yeah did the CIA do
that today today rich white tower seven
yeah they got well they got the
Hillary's a lizard and she took tower
seven and put charges in it yeah and
they make a [ __ ] frogs day all right
take it easy Alex well why don't you
tell me why the tower seven fell on its
own well if you're so I'm here with a
Navy SEAL I'm a Navy SEAL
I I am I'm a Navy SEAL I own eighty
seven dogs and all of them were trained
by Nate and when I was the governor of
Minnesota I had over a hundred dogs now
let's say you to that well if you're
such a patriot I don't know how 9/11 you
know what happened I guess she wants to
been there I'm I guess you must have
been there I wasn't and they would tell
you that oppressive canario that six
presa canarios could say take down a
building because that's not factual I
was not gonna say that I was gonna say
they could four of them could take out a
nuclear submarine it's not free I had
them doing it in the Marines I don't
know about that I was a Navy SEAL I know
you were you said I live in the Baja all
right I don't I I spent less than six
months a year in the continental United
States of America I have a thousand
gallons of potable water don't know what
you're saying I have a silo full of
tortilla okay but what is the point of
what is that why don't you tell me I
don't know man tell me why don't you
tell me what the point is follow you're
such a patriot I am a patriot but you
know what you have a stylo phone we want
to show us pictures of shaven and shorn
chimps and you and you've never stepped
in the in the in the arena of battle
with a chimp and when I do you'll be
thumbing your ass for sure
because I have gone in hand-to-hand
combat with many chips you have yes
armed only with a polar bear femur and
that's something you don't know anything
about because you I'll be over there
in Danang and I'll be over there on the
Ho Chi Minh Trail there's no chance
there and and I'll take the chimps in
with me while you're over here taking
patty-cake lessons I'm not high with
your box war is over
Vietnam War never started what what what
did you just say I said the Vietnam War
started so that it could never end never
stir circuit I've never said that you I
don't know I don't you tell me what I
[ __ ] know I'm trying to tell you
Jesse I'll tell you what I said what did
you say I said the Vietnam War was
started by chimpanzees why don't you
tell me why I can't tell you the more
their sign in order so what did the
chimps do they started the war I
wrestled Bob Backlund for 45 minutes in
the Philadelphia spectrum well fine but
that does one draw it doesn't make so
why don't you tell me how all right you
know what get him out of here
all right fine ha leave bye bye guys
that guy's so hard to follow [ __ ] is he
doing I don't know man he's just [ __ ]
Jesse Ventura just runs in here and
[ __ ] your podcast yeah he doesn't he's
in control
no sense yeah well there's security here
for real he's huge so what do you guys a
big guy yeah all right anymore anyway
sorry I look how big you are when you
take the butt of a shotgun to the face
you're gonna drop to your knees and
that's something you've never felt Bryan
Callen I know a thing or two I've I've
served with women in the Marines I said
you're in the seals right I was in the
Navy SEALs okay but you said the Marines
just well I did not say that that's not
what I said I said I had a secret I had
a secret team of a dozen women and me I
don't and we would go yes we would and
we went to Cambodia together and then
what did you do at Camp oh he took out
the enemy and then we had sex we had sex
have you ever had 13 some I've never had
have all right you're not a patriot if
you haven't had a 13 son I don't think
that's a good man 12 Navy SEALs built
like Linda Hamilton and I'll tell you
another thing what they sure did
[ __ ] my shotgun that day okay Jesse
you've got to get out of here right now
we're doing fine
bye-bye giant they don't there's a piece
of paper that says we're recording in
these the governor of Minnesota stop the
governor this is so crazy because it's
our first short-side fog and Donald
Trump just walked in and I cannot
believe we waited oh yes we need a big
guest yeah Will Sasso was like I won't
do the show and I was like dude but
Donald Trump's coming in though he said
there was gonna be surprised
hi president elect Donald Trump a
welcome to I can't believe how are you
this is tremendous I love being here I
love a fighter in the kid one of my
absolute favorite broadcasts yeah and I
think what you guys are doing is
tremendous it's terrific but a couple of
great guys by the way you know it's
great thank you for graduations well
thank you very much you know we've been
on that we've been on the campaign trail
we've been doing rallies I wanna do
rallies I'm gonna keep doing rallies
he's gonna do anymore well I'm going to
keep doing them I was doing six a day
sometimes seven Donald can I ask you a
question were you surprised that you won
the election because you were high no
okay but you work use me yeah but you
were behind it excuse me you were behind
though so no no and that's I think we're
wrong the polls were wrong Brennan is
right in the polls are wrong but and if
you've heard me say this before I've
said this before
Brendan is right and the polls are wrong
I believe I've said I've never heard you
say I said that I really say the thing
is you know that corporate news monster
wants you to believe this and that they
want you to believe that I'm a crazy guy
that I'm somebody who's Donna find the
word doggone it Donald at can I
interrupt you you do and you
there are a lot of PC's me there are a
lot of people that are disenfranchised
in this country there are a lot of
people are looking Hillary I mean
looking what Hillary said she said
they're deplorable no no that's how what
I'm talking about bends their agenda
like that starts with D I know but a lot
of a lot of syllables a lot gay
everybody loves my vocabulary no well I
have some of the best syllables I people
know this probably but Donald look a lot
of gay Americans black Americans Latino
Americans are worried
I let her knockin rific people terrific
people know that's not true right but
that's not true at all I've got a a plan
yeah we're going to make America great
again it's gonna be fired up saying I
fired up having people by the [ __ ] well
no see now that's not exactly true a lot
of people thought well you know he's
asking I'm like him
yeah all right excuse me Brennan's
asking me straightforward questions no
the truth of the matter is that when
those words were said it was actually
Billy Bush who said that no I die no no
no Brennan Billy Bush is the bad guy not
dominant give me ten million dollars to
one of those charities that they had on
the John Oliver show I don't know I
couldn't even figure it out there's so
many so many he's a petty put on he's a
big John Oliver no no John Oliver is a
pig not only was the British Lee but no
Billy Bush is a tremendous guy is a
great guy now John Oliver that is a
British pig dog okay well that's true
and he went on his program very unfair
very sad okay excuse me excuse me very
unfair he went on his program and he
said he said well he said he said no he
excused me he said that everybody should
give to charities that this is not
normal well I think excuse me I think
this is a spitting in the face of
America we're gonna make excuse me we're
gonna make America great again there's a
lot of disenfranchised people who work
and you a lot of gays work and yet a lot
of them have jobs
of course yeah of course there yes yeah
people even gay people okay yeah
they have jobs can black people and then
what about the wall u-turned going to
build a wall
do you not like don't I like everybody
what are you still gonna do some stuff
with the WWE like you're gonna still
Vince and Linda a tremendous friends of
mine I love Vince and Linda I might give
Linda an ambassadorship what would you
say to the people that didn't vote for
you Donald look we had a lot of people
on the other side this is about us
everybody
excuse me well this is about getting
everybody but what would you say the
people that didn't that don't don't like
you and I take him to the street in that
life I I don't
Dave Cheadle did not vote on II don t
know don cheadle did not vote for me he
did his monologue and when that was
cheated Dave Chappelle he said that he
did he didn't vote but he's gonna give
me a chance and I love Don Chappelle and
I think he's a tremendous it stay out of
tissue over here Brendon little water a
tissue
Brendan Sidney a little oh it's gonna be
fine I guess it's fine
Bennett is trying to I think he's trying
to get me off that you have a little
tissue right there you can use for some
reason is it roll of toilet paper but
it's like we're done it's about us and
and Tim done done Donald let's - jump in
there Dave are you gonna hurt prosecute
Hillary Clinton
I love Hillary she's wonderful she's a
tough woman she's a tough woman
she's good friend she called to
congratulate me bill called to
congratulate me right essentially
anybody that I meet or talk to is okay
but everyone what about Hulk Hogan
though I love Hulk Hogan I've met Hulk
Hogan tremendous guy I heard he gave you
a call when you he gave me a call he
gave me a call he was very gracious he
said it was one of the most unbelievable
runs he's ever seen he said it may have
even been better than his world
championship run oh wow
1982 okay well I want to thank you for
coming by
yeah it's a big show for Sam I'm very
excited this is gonna be a new America
and I want to say I'm very proud of you
boys thank you I don't think that you
should have left
Fox oh but I do but I do think that
megyn kelly is very unfair but I love
megyn kelly but she's been very unfair
and if you can get have her on the show
here I wouldn't oppose but I will not
come back if you have Meghan okay he's
not coming okay so then you guys go to
Fox News if you did the fighter the kid
and the billionaire no in Fox News I
like that and then and then I like where
your head's at well how about the
fighter in the kid and the
president-elect yes that's a great idea
it's not made idea yeah sure well thank
you darling so much okay bye
Stone Cold Steve Austin was on the show
yesterday and he was saying how awesome
he's asking about snapchat he was asking
about yeah he's like should I get on
snapchat
I need snaps I'm like I got all them
[ __ ] filters you can make your face
look like a little [ __ ] girl with the
shiny [ __ ] diamonds and [ __ ] hell you
could even have a [ __ ] clown face or
a [ __ ] dog with where your tongue
comes out he's if you don't want to see
Stone Cold Steve Austin as a dog a cute
dog with his tongue flapping out give me
a hell yeah
what oh yeah Brian don't do that while
I'm doing it I'm just doing a little bit
of a bit but we like to hey that's what
big killers we fed yeah bit killer I
mean I'm I'm Steeve cold
Stone Cold Steve Austin Colbert stone
Steve sleep holder's icy cold
that's hot stone it's not bad yeah I do
would you like to yes okay let's play a
little game all right you give me an
impersonation
maybe something you've never heard me do
before maybe maybe something that I
can't do and then I'll do it
and then you do the shitty version and
I'm all autonomy black I'm pretty good
man that's tough you know what I mean
you've done it but I'd like to compare
the two
I'd like just Trump let's start easy
let's start easy with Trump you're
already making the face because you
don't know what you're doing yes don't
[ __ ] like talk about I drink don't
judge my [ __ ] well that wouldn't meet
just so I'm not biased me chin and agent
a will vote super I love it
okay here's here's a little bit we're
gonna yeah we're gonna just do something
a little simple saying yeah okay let's
paint a scenario let's pretend we're in
the Oval Office yeah we're just having a
little fun Donald Trump let's say he's
watching me and Kellyanne Conway he
would say yeah Bend you over and [ __ ]
hard well now you say it I'm not gonna
say something that y know Asajj honest
okay because and I really mean this it's
cheating that's actually not bad and
it's mean it's not bad yeah that's
actually pretty good yeah I have nothing
to do with Russia Russia Russia you got
to put a little rest I have nothing to
do with the Russian Russia say China
I have no whisper China China knows
whisper China China but missing family
China China China China China that's
pretty good it's not bad
that's really good I'm a brilliant mimic
keep going what else was another one
I am Ray Romano I've never done oh it's
a relevant automation that kids need to
hear yeah like my brother bhai well we
found drinks my brothers tall my brother
my brother's taught olds me what to do
with my my parents are here it's been a
long time since I've never tried that's
terrible don't stop back it's so bad
hold on it's it can you commit the Frog
if similar the same ring why are there
so many they say John Denver's John
Denver yeah you know Linda Ronstadt
now Linda Ronstadt yay [ __ ] [ __ ] sad
it's so sad for me to do that's when you
know you get hermit B frog
I am permit d yeah [ __ ] I am Kermit
the Frog I didn't grow up with these
guys you didn't grow up why not
you study Rea well let me give you this
Clint Eastwood oh yeah
let him go first I'm not doing no Clint
Eastwood you can hey I think he yeah
Diane Diane ain't much of a living boy
yeah Diane Diane ain't much of a living
all right this one's on you work it give
me your best Russian will end on this
give me your best Robin Russian Russian
I would like to do John Malkovich in
rounders oh my god one of my favorites
all day he chick-chick-chick pay him
Pierre that me and his Manny that's
pretty [ __ ] good I would like to do
just a Russian but I have to think about
what kind of rock oh very good
give me a Siberian KGB operative deep
just just in a snow cover and say are
you are here not for Wallis but because
you've got enemy of the state
all right Sam I Dracula because I was
pretending to be Dracula but in fact I'm
from Russia you must die because what a
mere poop it's pretty good it's pretty
good yeah I'm very good impressions are
stupid I like Dracula I've always liked
I've always wanted to be I've always
wanted to say this and I don't know how
to do it but when the wolves howl we're
gonna howl and I want you to say ah the
children of the night what sweet music
they make no way so as Dracula as
Dracula and I'd like you to be involved
in this too way I'm howling well yo how
if you want to do Dracula and try your
hand at Dracula you can hear it so
beautiful and then you say ah the sweet
children of the night what's the second
part what sleep music what sweet music
they play right they make they make yeah
but do it with a little more relish
ah they sweet are the sweet children I
the children of the night what sweet
music they make ah they children I'm let
me try ah the children of the night what
sweet music they make it's a little yeah
come on come on dude yeah guys this is
my biggest role to date almost watching
the history well let's cut to a clip
let's cut to a clip oh yeah you guys
have a clip of Arnold Schwarzenegger's
drag yeah you gotta tell us about
working with Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Arnold Schwarzenegger's Dracula it
must've been amazing it was really or
the wolf right it was the wolf and you
have that scene where you guys
communicate you know I got to say he did
a great job he was he was scary and I
drank believable he was very disciplined
why we cut to a clip here we are here's
a clip of Arnold Schwarzenegger in
Arnold Schwarzenegger's Dracula these
sweet did children of the night yeah
what sweet music did it make yeah I'm
Dracula it's so much range oh yeah this
is most like yes just now the Bob dude
you're like was half Wardrobe in half
like was that like that Andy Serkis CGI
yes and Bob you look amazing how about
this we found a clip of Donald Trump
back in 1987 what when he wanted to be
an actor I don't know if you ever saw
that well they Dracula that's right he
was in that dancers in Donald Trump's
critic and we have a clip where the guy
says would you like some wine and and
Donald as Dracula said no I never I
never drink vine and it's really okay
look yeah have a look so why don't we
cut to that clip that's all he says
though count would you like some wine no
I never drink wine Oh
and they're there a lot the best
scariest notes carriers are like Donald
Inc commits to the roll you guys also
have a clip of is this true hulk hogan
he was do
ww that's like expendable for nine yeah
he plays Dracula yeah it was like right
in between no-holds-barred and suburban
demands the Wolves again and what was
the line well it was are the children of
the night yeah what sweet music they
make I can't wait to get my hands on
them oh okay that's right got that yeah
okay I want to cut to the clip yeah
yeah yeah dude wolf ruler are the
children of the night dude
what sweet music they make brother yeah
dude yeah broiler would you like some
lime count no dude I never drink wine
brother and milk is for babies awful
Alfred you got a drink beer dude or
unless you're making a protein shake
brother crack a few eggs and they're
awful Alfred and then you could drink it
back we put a banana in there we put
this special green powder dude and then
any blood and then the blood I want to
drink your protein blood we're back yeah
he's really really good yeah that was
really amazing let's have a look at this
clip are the children of the night what
sweet music they make I forgot about Ray
Romano playing drag my wolf brother was
very tall and my wolf parents are here
and my wolf wife wants to go to the
ballet but I want to watch football
really good Wow Romano really relevant
impersonations to that all the
youngsters miss 1999 and Bryan 50 in
1999 and will is only 15 years old and
soon they're both gonna be in Hollywood
Bryan's much older will as much younger
cuz he's a millennial P&H it feels so
good Dabangg Chang medibang better dang
this is my favorite line of that whole
song it's like no they're not gonna
forget about the drive I put down
they're done and pick up the cup and
throw your hands up
father you say if can burn doctor this
is how we do it when you see my back
rippling I pull myself up like a champ
like a chimp thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift